[Music]
there is fantastic rich complexity in
the world around us but the beauty and
the cruelty of existence is not
something we can always handle alone
[Music]
that struggle to survive extends beyond
humans and includes all life on the
planet there a seemingly endless
menagerie of creatures to live compete
and sometimes help one another as they
populate the earth even the very
smallest are an important part of this
web of life but how did this come to be
for us to find out let's go back to a
time of ancient competition and see how
a simple prokaryotic cell no more than a
membrane nucleic acids and proteins
evolved a remarkably beneficial
relationship to help it thrive
billions of years ago these early cells
lived in rich waters searching for
energy some cells concealed energy from
molecules directly some of those cells
became energy sources for others while
still other cells evolved the ability to
use sunlight to split water molecules as
an energy source but the pure oxygen
released in this reaction changed the
very atmosphere of the planets and
likely harmed other prokaryotes many
didn't survive but what's this here is
the cell that evolved to use oxygen as a
powerful energy source allowing it to
thrive in this new oxygen-rich
environment but the cells still competed
for survival in a dangerous world then
something remarkable happened a larger
cell engulfed our little oxygen using
cell but this time the little cells
survived inside its host now the smaller
cell could harness energy from oxygen
but this time from the safety of its new
home even more energy than it needed
allowing it to share energy with the
larger whole cell in return the host
cell provided nutrients and safety from
predators this relationship was simply
too good to end over generations the two
cells descendants exchanged DNA and
became dependent on each other for
survival living as one organism in an
evolutionary process called
endosymbiosis this mutually beneficial
relationship only deepened over time
allowing the evolution of what we know
today as the eukaryote with a true
nucleus and organelles that complete
specialized tasks
and what about that little oxygen
consuming cell it evolved into the
mitochondrion which still harnesses most
of the energy in eukaryotic cells in
your own body right now a mitochondrion
can maintain an electric field across
its membrane of 30 million volts per
year a potential that is equal to the
energy released by a bolt of lightning
in the sky this energy supported the
evolution of even more structures in
more diverse combinations changing and
building on one another over time all of
the varied multicellular life on earth
derives from that cooperative
relationship in our ancient past had it
not been for this chance relationship so
long ago life on earth wouldn't exist as
it does today it all began with cells
evolving to cooperate and create new
possibilities for life
[Music]